la illaha illallah more handy bismillah
hamdulillah assalamu alaikum peace be
unto you welcome to the Dean show if
you're not in Chicago people from all
around the globe tune in to the Dean
show calm all of our shows are there we
like to help bring out and help you
understand Islam which is the
fastest-growing way of life and we bring
our guests from all around the globe
we're at the journey of faith and when
we come back we're going to be helping
you giving you some techniques talking
about the importance of seeking
knowledge the benefits some of the
techniques so you do not want to go
anywhere we'll be right back with our
next guest sheikh waleed abdul hakim
here on the Dean show love there's only
one Mohammed is His Messenger a la la
ha there's only one button Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice
assalamualaikum I comstock to like it
but I can't you please be up to you it's
beyond tier two thank you very much
you're welcome for being with us I think
it's my pleasure actually may Allah
reward you for coming all the way from
Chicago you too and you're welcome in
Toronto thank you very much it's a
pleasure to be here we want to talk
about something that's very important
seeking knowledge we want to be those
who are in the higher levels so we want
to worship our Creator properly and you
need the knowledge yes bismillah al
hamdulillah autosum allah so allah i
start with the name of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala the glorified people always
ask about what is the best way or how
can i go to the highest level of
paradise and if you think about it
logically if we think about it the
person could for example they could pray
all their life long they could fast
every day of their life they could go
every single year to the pilgrimage to
Hajj they could become rich and then
spend all their money but really again
this is limited because the person is
limited by the time of their death the
average person the Prophet peace be upon
him told us that the average person life
from among his nation is between 60 and
70 years so how would then that lifetime
the person could go to the highest level
of paradise our Prophet peace be upon
him taught us that if someone if someone
who seek knowledge taught someone else
for example how to pray then every
single time this person prays the person
whom he taught the other person who
taught him would get the rewards for it
so if I teach hundred people how to pray
and they're praying all their life on
the day of judgment and my scale if
allah wills i will have the reward of
all the prayers they did combined so
that that way i'm getting several
lifetimes
of Deeds just by teaching people
knowledge and for that reason the person
one of the best ways to go to the
highest level of paradise is the person
seeks knowledge and teaches it to people
now you are out you actually have an
impressive resume I mean you are
somebody who's been studying Islam for
about 20 years that correct in Saudi
Arabia some of it was I was in
elementary school and it was an islamic
school in saudi arabia which has a
little bit different curriculum than the
regular school over there and then I'll
hamdullah thanks to Allah after that I
graduated and I went to study in the
university and also as you know because
it is mainly the country where Islam
started that there are there are so many
almost in every mosque there is always
lessons of knowledge by what some of the
best scholars in the world so handle
other poor slave allah that allah to
create for him to be there that i was
able to benefit and take advantage i
think i added from over there and we got
to poor slaves right here for slaves
slaves of the creator we're all proud to
be slaves of the crater and not slaves
to the material world that's a beautiful
thing isn't it absolutely they are all
slaves Allah and this is something we
were taught that the person would try to
refrain from the using the word I as
much as possible so they wouldn't be
bragging it's more that everything good
happened to us is because Allah has
decreed it and has given it to us as a
benefit and as from his blessings and we
are here to learn and it's a blessing to
have individuals such as yourself that
we can learn from and then we can put it
out to the whole world that they can
benefit from this knowledge that you
have gained alhamdulillah praises to the
crater that have is an earth now also
tell us you have a master's degree in
islamic studies i'm still working on a
master's degree in islamic studies i
finished hamdulillah thanks doll i
finished a master's degree in life
skills training great so we're going to
be getting some good advice and shut off
from somebody who knows this Dean this
way of life tell us now we have so many
people embracing Islam embracing that
way of total submission surrender
to a man to a woman but the one who
created man and woman the Creator that
happens in earth yes so now it's very
important that people they've realized
that I don't want to worship anyone but
the Creator and Muhammad peace be upon
him is the last and final message just
like Jesus Moses Noah and all the other
prophets that proceeded to him they were
messengers they were the ones they were
the way the truth from the light showing
us how to worship the crater correctly
this way of life has been saved and we
have everything that we need to learn we
don't have to invent things and make up
things on our own so tell us for that
person and even people who've been in
this way of life but now they've been
procrastinating a little bit we want to
create this enthusiasm and show us the
proper way how to start let's say
someone just took Shahada yeah it just
took this testimony of faith their
Muslim now yes what are the steps
because I see a lot of people they come
into it they still haven't even
established a prayer yes so what are the
some of the techniques because it can be
overwhelming at times it's so much
knowledge how much a day how much do you
take in so you don't overburden yourself
talk to us about this please absolutely
and if you allow me I would you rewind
just a little bit before what about
someone before they accept Islam or know
about it again I'm they're seeking
knowledge is for everyone not just for
Muslims and what I want to say is the
person first of all you mentioned
procrastination this this is something
the person should not procrastinate upon
because if the time of your death comes
that's it for you that's the end of it
here your endless life to be tested and
how would I know from all the religions
around the world wii u have Islam
Christianity Judaism Buddhism all these
religions and too many choices how could
the person know what is the right
religion and what and that comes by
seeking knowledge because we have to
know that Allah our Creator is just and
he wouldn't just let people in confusion
about the different religions there must
be there has to be a religion that is
the correct religion among all of these
otherwise the people would not know how
to worship their creator and the only
way the person would know what is this
religion is they have to go and
investigate they should take some part
of their life and do
this as soon as possible and try to
learn as much as they can about
different religions and then they would
make the choice and I know that if the
person sincerely does this without any
bias that they would find the message of
worshiping Allah alone and submitting to
him which we call Islam and which was
the same religion for all four before
the religion of Prophet Muhammad the
religion of Jesus peace be upon him and
Moses and everyone now coming to your
question about the new Muslim who just
accepted Islam tell me one thing before
you go on gallows I want to just ask you
one question in relating to this we
don't have to rewind again yes does
Islam encourage someone who now might
have been brought up as a Christian as a
Hindu and you know what they're saying
that this whole man got thing that God
is a man God died for my sins or that
the multitude of God's it doesn't make
sense doesn't go with my nature as Islam
encouraged that people investigate that
do we say Islam is it and that's it I
can't look at anything else or does
Islam encourage that go ahead look at
everything else and you'll find out by
looking at these things that that's not
the truth that this is what would be the
most rational logical and provides the
most evidence can a person do that the
person Allah when he sent the Quran yes
the message the message there is is is
logical and at the same time it's
challenging the person it's actually it
tells the person go and search oh yeah
go in search and go and see and and you
will find for yourself that for example
when God challenging them could you
bring even one verse by your own first
he challenges them to bring a book like
the Quran that could you bring one verse
like this so the person is being
challenged and in fact the person is is
ordered to reflect and to try to arrive
at the correct solution at the the the
the solution that will save him on the
day of judgment which is worshipping God
alone now the person obviously if we
have several religions we can't say
they're all right at the same time it's
impossible because logically if someone
says something this piece of paper is
white and someone else says it's black
and it only has one color it's either it
could be either it be that color or this
color one is right what is wrong one is
right it can they can be so if one
religion tells
need that a man was our Jesus Pete one
was was a messenger another religion
says it's God and they contradict each
other one of them has to be right they
can't be both right we can't say all
religions are right so the question now
is logic if we're going to speak
logically it's either either either or
wrong or one of them has to be right
there is no other third argument so in
that case what is the right one the
person has to do a search and learn the
knowledge of several and then they would
as I said because God is just they would
if they are sincerely doing this without
any advice they would have to find what
is the correct religion now if a person
says you know what all religions are the
same what do you respond to this with
they say they're all this is all
man-made well one of the claims that we
hear often is that all religions preach
good so it doesn't matter if I follow
one or the other but really upon
examining the religions more thoroughly
we would see that yes all religions
maybe we'll tell you don't lie don't
steal but how what's the correct
solution how could we achieve a society
that would not do all these wrongdoings
there has to be a system and this system
we have to take it as a whole we can't
break one part of it and do the other so
in this case if someone tells about for
example Islam about the punishment for
four thieves someone might say well this
is injustice but wait a minute what
about first these occur which was it is
the the charity that the person it has
to give it some obligation on him to
give every year that is enough they said
it's enough to fulfill all the the
poverty in the world which was
calculated to be close to two and a half
percent the same the same that is
dictated in Islam so we have to apply it
as a system and Islam is different
because it gives you a solution it
doesn't just tell you this thing is
wrong stay away from it or this thing is
right it's a whole system that works and
it has worked it has been tested it's
not something we're going to test and
see if it works or not and we see this
one when Islam wanted to make a
whole forbidden because it causes as you
see it's the number one cause of crime
in the developed country and in the
world so if the person they tried in the
United States in close to the 30s they
tried for several years to ban it and
people protested and did all these
things and it didn't stop them yeah but
Islam in the three-stage process it was
able it made people from within
themselves stop completely to drink yeah
so that way Islam shows us that it has
the solutions it doesn't just tell you
this is wrong or this is right it gives
practical solutions for practical
problems that are going on it makes
sense yes and there is no problem except
there is a solution for it and either he
found it in the Quran or at the book of
the Muslims or the the sooner the the
narrations of the prophet or it is
derived from these two sources by
analogy now I was told you were actually
born in the US I was born yes in Lansing
Michigan lansing michigan now you live
in canada now i live in canada moved
recently to canada i was in ohio about
two years ago and i just moved to canada
recently okay tell us now this is very
interesting so if a person goes out he's
sincere he wants to know the truth he
asked the Creator guide me I know my
purpose in life and he starts to
investigate eventually he'll be guided
to Islam surrender submission to the
creator of the heavens and earth without
any associates makes sense huh
absolutely I could because once he
compared and they see this was the only
religion and the world that was
preserved and in fact look at any
Scripture and this is not our sayings
the people for who follow those
religions they say that the Scriptures
has been modified in one way or the
other where the Quran we have it and its
entirety let's err four letter word for
word dartford it's safe it's a not
corrupted it's not altered edited by man
it's not edited by Minotaur we do have
translations is something different
where someone is translating their
thoughts but we have the original the
original was not lost like many other
religions we have the original and the
Arabic language in its entirety so when
the Muslims those who have submitted
themselves to their Creator say that we
have a living miracle yes give us
another point because you
just told us about this miraculous
nature that people can go and check the
authenticity of this book tell us
something else that comes to mind for
someone who's maybe involved in science
or something tangible that he can go
test this with it's a first if we talk
about a miracle notice that all prophets
and all messengers sent by God piece on
the peace be upon them they were there
they they came with a miracle so that
people would know if they are genuine
profit or not now all those miracles we
haven't witnessed any of them and there
is only one of them left for example you
could tell me about the division of the
sea that happened that was the miracle
of Moses peace be upon him you could
tell me about the miracles of Jesus or
someone else but I didn't see them so
for me that's not a proof because I
didn't see them and had the Quran did
not tell me about it I wouldn't believe
it but this because the Quran told me I
believe it now for a person who's living
now and there is no more profits coming
how would I know if Islam was the
genuine religion that's why for that
reason God the final miracle is is the
quran the word of god it's preserved so
that all the nations that would come
after would be able to be guided to the
correct religion so this is a miracle
that lives on forever not know in terms
of the miracles in the quran there are
so many types for so many different
people there is logical miracles there
is linguistic miracles there is even
laws of society miracles and the laws of
society there is scientific miracles and
the person could easily search for for
these miracles either through a book or
for the internet now there is no excuse
for anyone not to seek the knowledge
knowledge now is just a few clicks away
from you so go and see [ __ ] from
authentic sources and see where there's
this is going to guide you and and try
to ask put some questions that you have
about the purpose of life and all these
things and try to do maybe you could put
it even in a sheet or excel file try to
compare this religion says this is
religion says this and then at the end
see which one is the one that is
compatible the one that is more logical
the one that is is has no mistake
here and there you cannot find any
mistake in the Quran as God challenge
can't have no contradiction because no
one they still can be from the crater
yes if it has even one mistake it's not
from the Creator absolutely people
already are benefiting from this
knowledge God willing and this is the
importance of gaining knowledge because
now many people if they're sincere
they're going to be enlightened and
hopefully God willing they're going to
continue on coming back every week and
doing some more investigating now tell
us for those who have we did a reverse
now we're going to come back to where we
were those that have acknowledged that
there is no deity worthy of worship
except the creator of the heavens and
earth in Arabic we say Allah yes and the
Muhammad is the last and final messenger
and then you except when you make this
statement Jesus Moses knowing all the
other messengers because God Almighty
said the same message submit to him
alone yes and this is summed up with one
word Islam isn't it yes yes LEM infamous
oh now tell us for that person who has
taken the first step some people they
drift off there's a lot of delights a
lot of distractions of this world and
they don't continue on seeking knowledge
or sometimes we get forgetful give us
some advice for those who have come to
this realization give us some practical
tips I'll give you exactly a narration
from the Prophet peace be upon him that
this actually tells us exactly where the
person who nearly became muslin accepted
the message how they would start in
there seeking knowledge the Prophet
peace be upon him sent the companion
moradabad jebel he sent him to at that
time the country of Yemen yes and he
wanted him they were recently becoming
Muslims and he wanted to give them a
guideline so he told him this is your
mission first go to them I'm just I'm
just translating or elaborating on the
hadith not doing a literal translation
he said go to the people of Yemen and
teach them and tell them the first thing
which is what we call the Shahada that
there is no no true god except allah and
that muhammad is his messenger and if
and only if if they follow you in this
statement then the next step is tell
them that God has decreed on them five
prayers that they
established in the day and in the night
five times a day the Muslims pray and
this is what we call is is this is the
the pillar of Islam because this is as
they say this is the pass or fail
criterion if you pray you will then
based on your other deeds you may go to
paradise or go apart Leigh and how it
fair for any since that you did that
we're Unforgiven or major sins and then
you go to paradise but if you didn't
pray them then you're not guaranteed the
salvation and then if they follow you in
this then tell them that God has ordered
you to give a percentage of your money
to the poor not from your income of what
you make but the left overs love at the
end of the yes left over so I make
100,000 and I spent it all I don't have
to give anything but I made less than
that 50,000 and at the end of the year I
have 10,000 left so that means that
spare money that I don't need so only
two and a half percent of that amount I
would give to the poor which is very
little very easy and if they do this
then tell them that God has decreed on
them too fast one month a year which is
the month of Ramadan from down to sunset
which is which puts there's a lot of
benefits for it that's not the focus of
our talk but it's it's it's a training
for self discipline for the person when
the person learns how to stop and do
something that is permissible which is a
food and drink you learn for 30 days
stop go stop go this in the same way
you're able to do this then you are even
more trained to do that with things that
are unlawful or I'm permissible I could
easily stop myself from stealing from
doing adultery from doing anything else
because I trained for something that is
even permissible and then if they do
that then the last pillar which is the
pilgrimage once in your lifetime you go
to Mecca if you could afford it and if
you have the necessary conditions to do
it if you can't afford it it drops from
you so it's a very simple religion to
follow these are the five main pillars
and you just have to stay away from the
unlawful
anything more than that is to increase
your level in paradise now after this
Shahada the testimony swearing about nor
the deity but the one true God Allah and
Muhammad is the last and final messenger
and the prayer comes next this is very
important what should a new Muslim do as
far as the prayer does he have to
instantly know everything the opening
chapter the what to say and prostration
or does he just have to go through the
movements give us some techniques on a
daily regimen how much time should he
spent learning the prayer should he
start learning the prayer right away
tell us how he should set it up so he
can have something more structure so
it's easier on him no its elaborate on
what I just said the same steps and in
that one mentioned in the narration are
the same steps for the person when they
start seeking knowledge once they know
the correct religion and the correct
concept of God they learn about the
prayer and Allah has told us in the
Quran that the person that Allah does
not decree on the person what they are
not able to do so there's no excuse now
I got work I got college that it's two
holes no excuse plus the person could
learn step by step if something they
can't learn or can't grass now they
could learn it step by step there is
there is no force in this the person
just has to try their best they would
first learn how how to pray which is
something very simple they would learn
the movements they would learn just a
few words they could do it in their
language until they learn how to recite
it in Arabic a very simple short
passages they would know the meaning of
it outside of their prayer there's a lot
they could pray to God directly in
whatever language they want but inside
and also this is a symbol because this
is the religion the language of the
religion to be preserved that the person
has to know just just minimum just
enough so that they would be tied to the
original message the original language
this is not a language that died like
Latin or anything else this is a
language they're still alive and spoken
by spoken as the first language by a
quarter billion people and spoken as a
second language by at least 1 billion
people so this is a miracle in itself
that you're learning
the original language that the message
was revealed in because we don't have
the original message that was revealed
to Jesus peace be on or Moses they
didn't speak English did they no no no
now as soon as you translate it over to
another language you lose the meaning
and a lot of thing so you're learning
the original language that it was
revealed in step by step and we have to
know when we read the translation we're
reading the understanding of that
translator that person of the message
which could be a it could be accurate
could be a little bit inaccurate it
could be they're translating from one
perspective someone else translate from
a different perspective but when you
have the original anyone who challenges
me about our challenge is the person
about the translation we could go back
to the original and see what did this
language mean and since people still
speak Arabic until today it's very easy
to check this so we would know how this
message is applied something that is
very beautiful about the Quran is God
has made it so that the religion is
applicable and in every time on the
place in the past now and in the future
we have fixed parts fixed laws these
will not change with time stealing was
was wrong and unlawful it will always be
unlawful it's not going to change in the
future become level however we also have
flexible parts of the religion that that
could be adapted to the invit to diplay
swear people are and to the time so for
example the laws of buying and selling
now in the past we were using gold and
silver now we could use papers we could
use checks these are very flexible
because they are applied within culture
the clothing we have general outline but
also there is a cultural element in it
the person could wear whatever is people
wear in their region so that's why this
is why this religion is a pliable and
all times in all places because you have
the fixed part which doesn't change and
you have the part that could be
adaptable and how do we adapt it not to
our whims and desires we go back to the
original message in arabic and see could
we take that ruling out of that verse or
that hadith or not this is amazing
another proof about proof that this is
the way of life that is left for all of
mankind IntelliJ IDEA judgment couple
more points yes before we come to an end
the
some of the benefits and some of the
good things the wisdom that comes from
establishing this prayer can you talk
about this quickly establishing this
prayer is this is the connection with
God and the person because they have to
face God they have to stand in front of
God five times a day so I know I can't
really do anything in between that is
unlawful how am I going to do something
that is wrong how am I going to steal
how am I going to look at something I
shouldn't look at or do adult you
anything when I know that just a couple
of hours i'm going to stand in front of
God how am I even going to have that
face so by establishing the prayer on
time I'm having the self-discipline of
time I'm also having reminding myself
always my connection with God that I
shouldn't do something wrong I might
fool people when there is no cameras
there is nothing I could do whatever I
want in a locked room but that is
watching me so I know this because I'm
going to stand in front of and that's
number one number two it's also it's
it's a way of uniting us all we're all
praying towards the same place Mecca
we're all we come five times and we go
to at least the the men they go to the
to the mosque so to the houses of
worship and they may meet each other and
they ask about each other how is your
family if someone is missing I would
know that this person it might be sick I
have to go and visit them I would
establish those ties family communities
the family and the community and then on
a bigger scale the friday prayer which
is the special friday player prayer with
the speech and then even on a bigger
scale and had in pilgrimage people come
from all over the world to meet in this
one place from all different races so by
establishing the prayer this reflects on
my whole life my connection with that
also makes me feel safe that whatever
bad things happen to me in this world i
still have my connection with god so i
know that no matter what happens i'm
going to be compensated on the day of
judgment but if i don't establish the
prayer I don't know I've just cut my
relationship with God yeah and this is
if I cut my relationship with that how
am I going to feel safe I'm driving I'm
going to be skilled all the time that
you know I'm fall into an accident and
died
and I'm not guaranteed salvation so
that's the problem so salvation when you
establish the prayer when I say
salvation I have to define it so our
non-muslim audience would not
misunderstand every Muslim who accepts
Islam and accepts that there is no god
but the true God will be guaranteed
salvation meaning they will go to
paradise as long as they don't associate
or worship someone else with God however
going to paradise directly is another
story if I if I become Muslim and I'm
still a bad person doing all wrong
things no I have to get punished and how
far eventually i will go to paradise
because I accepted the message but I'm
not guaranteed to go directly unless I
become a very good person in my whole
life and this is really different than
when we say that as someone died for
your sins all your sins are forgiven
automatically and then I could do
whatever I want so this is different
being a Muslim makes me want to reach
perfection every single aspect of my
life so establishing the truth and then
acting upon it doing the good that the
crater told you to yes your whole life
self-development yes a self-development
plus I'm not just it's not one paradise
fits all no I I want to get there's
different levels for a different if I
work hard and someone else is
procrastinating or lazy it's wouldn't i
can say what's just on what not to god
but the person would deserve to get
something better on the day of the
higher-ranking so high ranking so that's
why i want to reach perfection and
everything in my work with my
relationship with my wife and children
and parents and family and with my
brothers and sisters from islam i want
to reach perfection in every single part
of my life to be able to deserve to go
to that highest level in Paris oh thank
you very much tell us where people can
go to see some of your lectures or to
reach you if they need to you have a
website or yes thank you very much we
have a empath Elam is the Arabic word
for knowledge I l.m path p-a-t-h com one
word and we are launching this Institute
here in North America it's going to have
both courses on the spot in many major
cities and also online the courses of
our own path and they will
we have so far 188 courses that will be
offered within the next few years and
this will be translated and we're going
to teach these courses all over the
world so I encourage you all to come and
learn from it and benefit from it you
can find the lectures over there is no
God Almighty Allah rewards you thank you
very much thank you very much thank you
very much for being with us for another
episode of the Dean show you got to hear
the simplicity the rationale behind this
simple message submit not two years up
desires not to a man not to a monkey not
to the Sun the moon but the crater that
happens in earth establish a connection
when you love sum1 you want to talk to
them talk to your Creator through the
prayer tell them your problems tell them
you need because he's the only one that
can really bring solace to the hearts
and at the end it's nothing less than
paradise we hope to see you here next
time again on the Dean show until then
assalamu alaikum peace be unto you let's
see what everyone's talking about who if
you find one contradiction it can't be
from God but the rational idea the
rational explanation is you do your best
to give up for spring guidance I will
never give up spending this message hope
there you take that necessary step you
don't know if you're going to live till
tomorrow
so you got to find that urges you to do
the right thing right now the reality of
life usually doesn't sink in until
tragedy commas you get a few bad people
the media grabs ahold of that and spends
it the way they want to if you say that
you're not believe in Jesus you have
stepped outside of this nun you cannot
be a Muslim is that ended our faith to
to my brothers and sisters and on your
listeners whether you're an atheist jew
or your Christian how can we deny the
oneness of a creator the one that gave
us life he's got sustained I would read
the old and the New Testament now read
the final al Quran has been sent to
mankind as a source of healing and
guidance revealed to Mohammad now where
is recited by one and six people across
our sphere start your journey here and
if you're really you're sincere you come
to conclude it slams the only way to go
y'all let him know Eddie is the Dean
radio show